Speaker 1: Let's hear from people in the
audience. We take calls weekly via discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord. We
are going to start today with Daniel in
Raleigh. Raleigh, Raleigh. What is the right
pronunciation? Daniel. I never remember.
Speaker 3: It's Raleigh.
Speaker 1: Raleigh.
Welcome to the program, my friend.
Speaker 3: How are you doing, Mr. Packer?
Speaker 1: I'm doing.
Speaker 3: Well.
So my question is, what is your
opinion on the legalization and.
Speaker 4: Decriminalization
of marijuana at the federal.
Speaker 1: Level? I am completely in favor
of legalization at the federal level.
Speaker 3: And going kind of follow
up question is, what do you think is
needed for this to actually happen
in Congress? Obviously, it wouldn't
happen right now with a split Congress, but.
Speaker 1: Well, there's a couple of different
ways that it could happen. I actually think
more likely than just it's federally legalized,
it would be it's federally rescheduled so
that it's no longer a schedule one. More
states continue to legalize. And then there's
probably intermediate steps. I don't actually
think the most likely outcome is just a flat out
legalization federally right away. I think there's
going to be a bunch of intermediate steps.
Speaker 3: Could you briefly explain the
intermediate steps?
Speaker 1: Yeah. So,
for example, first it would be rescheduled so
to no longer be schedule one. More states would
legalize. There would be something more formal
from the federal government that no federal law
enforcement resources will be used to go after
state level cannabis. You know, we would have,
I don't know exactly every single step, but there
would it would be a sort of off ramp in my mind.
Speaker 4: All right. Thank
you so much for your questions.
Speaker 1: No, the question was yours.
I hope you're taking my questions.
No problem. I appreciate it so much.
Thank you. All right. There is Daniel.